aquí
[Música]
bienvenidos al papagayo
en este lugar trabajamos 16 personas
todos los días
intensamente día y noche
como para ver aquí seguimos comida la
gente viene a comer seguimos ricos vinos
entonces podría parecer bastante obvio
de qué se trata el papagayo pero qué
pensarían ustedes si hoy dijera que para
nosotros el papá eso no es un restaurant
yo soy cocinero pero hoy no voy a hablar
de cocina voy a hablarles de que pienso
yo sobre este negocio y en general sobre
cualquier negocio que emprenda
tal vez esto sea porque todos mis años
de entrenamiento como cocinero han
transcurrido fuera argentina
en países en donde las realidades las
ventajas y las dificultades son muy
distintas a las que afrontamos aquí ni
mejores ni peores distintas por ejemplo
en singapur en australia o en dinamarca
cuando escuchaba a alguna persona
planeando un proyecto gastronómico nunca
escuchaba
nada el dólar que subió bajaba no
existía la inflación aparentemente nadie
pensaba en poner una cortina metálica de
seguridad en diciembre el aporte del
restorán
allí los emprendedores siempre hablaban
de cómo lograr el mejor producto y sobre
todo yo siempre me acuerdo en mi primera
experiencia como consultor gastronómico
en dos hoteles uno en singapur y uno en
en chile para una gente de india y está
hecho ocho contándoles
al manager del proyecto como he hecho
para ahorrar bastante en equipamiento o
como he hecho para estrujar al máximo
los recursos humanos y para que sea más
rentable y mientras le contaba eso súper
animado el jefe me dice javier basta
para
deja de hacerle ahorrar plata a satin
del se llamaba él ya tiene mucha plata
no te preocupes pues intenta
de que todo lo que hagas sea excelente
sea una simple taza de café o un plato
de langosta si vos logras eso no hay
secretos y el negocio va a funcionar y
así he aprendido yo por varios años
después de un tiempo decidió volver a
argentina a cumplir el sueño del refrán
propio y nada menos que a córdoba un
ácido que me encanta cuando decido
contarle eso a mi familia a mis amigos
ya mis colegas la respuesta ha sido
unánime casi y muy poco alentador es la
verdad ese córdoba no porque córdoba
porque no haremos rectores de singapur o
en banco donde te han ofrecido a hacerlo
o bueno o en otro lado por lo menos en
buenos aires donde se acordó no tiene
turismo el cordobés no va a entender la
propuesta o el muy repetido el cordobés
es un rata
eso
no me causa mucha gracia a mí
y por dos razones número uno para mí
córdoba una hermosa ciudad y con una
gran potencial para emprender negocios
de calidad y número 2
creo
fervientemente en que cualquier proyecto
pensado con un concepto claro y sobre
todo pero sobre todo mucho mucho mucho
trabajo funciona en cualquier lugar del
mundo en australia en singapur en
bangkok y por supuesto en córdoba
finalmente el papayo abre en mayo de
2015 y desde ese día hasta hoy puedo
decir con alegría que funciona muy bien
con éxito estamos reservados
todos los días medio día y noche y a
veces con larga lista de espera más
largas de la que nos nos convendría
en los otros hace tres años hacemos las
cosas un poquito los primeros años me
dio por inercia tratando de que todo
funcione pero el último año hemos
empezado a tratar de ser un poquito más
consciente de lo que pasa hemos notado
que la gente que nos visita
y siente como una
no sé es como muy muy amable con
nosotros como yo nunca he trabajado
muchos restaurants y nunca he visto algo
así muy con muy comprometida y con
muchas ganas de que no vaya bien
y hemos empezado a pensar porque si
usted me preguntaron por qué hoy puedo
decirles con seguridad
que creo que la receta de este éxito
hasta hoy son dos cosas dos principios
no son ingredientes ni bebidas ni diseño
ni ninguna de esas cosas son dos
principios sobre el como trabajado desde
el primer día y yo creo que sólo los que
trabajaría en cualquier emprendimiento
que haga el primero
es el riesgo
no me pregunten por qué pero me aburro
muy fácil y no me gusta lo fácil me
gusta constantemente estar como ahí
caminando por la cornisa a punto de
caerme pero pero sabiendo que estoy
seguro
nosotros sabemos que para que pase algo
profundo en la gente no visita para que
no se olviden por un buen tiempo de
nosotros necesitamos que la gente cuando
entre restauran nos regale tres horas
para que nosotros podamos hacer lo que
se olviden de todo afuera y brindarles
toda nuestra hospitalidad y golpearlos
constantemente con estímulos todo el
tiempo desde que entran hasta que se van
la música al baño los platos las obras
de arte y todo y eso se logra solamente
arriesgando mucho constantemente para
poner los ejemplos claros el diseño
de acuerdo la primera vez que llevo a mi
viejo a la hora el papá de una persona
con cierta experiencia en construcción
entramos al aeropuerto de chapa y
entramos en este pasillo medio extraño
del ancho un poquito más ancho que esto
le muestra donde en la cocina donde
estaba el salón
buenísimo me dice que lindo y donde más
que más por donde no esto es todo
y ese cambio está loco y si la verdad
que sí si yo no me imagino un lugar
menos apto
para un negocio gastronómico que el
papayo tiene 2 metros 30 de ancho y es
tan angosto por el que dos camareros no
entran simultáneamente o en la cocina se
trabaja literalmente codo a codo
es muy difícil algunos dicen que el
resto angosto del mundo no lo sé pero la
realidad es que muy angosto
habiendo sorteado un poco el diseño en
forma creativa y en forma digamos con
mucha experiencia ha hecho que el
papagayo se posicione rápidamente como
uno de los ejemplos de restaurants en
espacios reducidos en todo el mundo
después también por no hablar de la
cocina
ningún cliente
sabe que va a comer hasta que llegue al
papagayo y lo más importante nosotros no
tenemos idea que vamos a cocinar hasta
que el cliente hasta un poquitito antes
del cliente del papagayo y eso es un
riesgo muy muy muy alto digamos
nosotros llegamos la mañana vemos que
hay hablamos con el verdulero con el
pescadero con el carnicero y le
empezamos a silbar en las cosas hablamos
el menú y diseñamos el menú de esa forma
y esto realmente muy arriesgado pero
nosotros necesitamos confianza a
nuestros clientes y de nosotros mismos
nosotros necesitamos saber y sabemos que
sabemos lo que hacemos y no tenemos
miedo
entonces esa sorpresa hace que los
clientes tengan un estímulo muy fuerte
también
y después cuando todo esto se torna un
poquito más cotidiano o casi aburrido de
vuelta necesitamos crear cosas nuevas
constantemente y un poquito más
desafiantes por ejemplo el año pasado se
nos ha ocurrido tener un restaurant muy
reconocido en europa y no solo el chef
sino a todo el restaurant cerrarlo
entero y traerle un mes a la ciudad de
córdoba de nuevo a córdoba algo que
nunca se ha dicho en argentina yo
hablando con mis colegas y con mis
amigos me decían javier no lo hagan los
costos son altísimos como se imaginarán
el cordobés de nuevo no está
acostumbrado y te voy a ir mal y como
bien me encanta pedir opinión en todo el
mundo y puede ser me encanta he traído
es el restaurant con todos sus empleados
por un mes y el resultado también ha
sido inédito en argentina 800 entradas
vendidas agotadas un mes y medio antes
que empiece el evento y 400 personas en
lista de espera y todos contentos y
nosotros también
el segundo principio
y es muy importante en la generosidad
y el dicho este es muy cierto uno recibe
en la medida de lo que da y nosotros en
el papá llevamos todo absolutamente todo
lo que tenemos sin medida
y eso se nota sabemos que un negocio que
tiene que ser rentable porque si no nos
hundiríamos básicamente pero también
sabemos que servir más vino o volver a
servir un plato cuando el cliente nos
pide no nos va a ser ni más ricos ni más
pobres lo que sí va a pasar es el
cliente lo va a notar y va a volver y se
va a ser amigo y va a volver con otros
amigos y hasta puede pasar lo que pasa
con gustavo un cliente nuestro que nos
ha confesado que últimamente cuando está
por entrar al restaurant sacar allá de
su casa para abrir la puerta
se siento como en casa y eso es muy
importante súper importante
y bueno y también hay que ser muy
generosos no solamente con esos clientes
sino con lo más importante que tenemos
son nuestros empleados
ellos van a desvivirse porque la gente
sea feliz solo si ellos son felices
y también que nuestro principal aliado
que son nuestros proveedores pues
nosotros haríamos absolutamente nada sin
los tomates de iván o si no vino de
emilio o sino que esos de jose
bueno hasta aquí tenemos las recetas
digamos estos dos ingredientes que hacen
que yo creo que hacen qué
casi nos aseguramos el resultado bueno
pero nosotros trabajamos muy fuerte la
verdad muy fuerte para conseguir algunas
noches que no son muy buenas noches
brillantes
noche que nuestros clientes no se
olviden por mucho tiempo y nosotros no
nos olvidamos por mucho tiempo y ahí
hace falta una cosita que es muy difícil
de
de describir
no sé si alguna vez le ha pasado que
no soy mi receta favorita por ejemplo de
mi abuela eran los malfatti de espinacas
de la salsa no entonces un día voy le
pidió a abuela enseñárselo malfatti y
vamos compramos la ricota la destinada a
los gritos ella cocker italiana l bajo
el laurel no sé qué no hace cuanto
hacemos los malfatti lo probamos
buenísimos muy buenos y voy hago lo
mismo invito a todos mis amigos de
santiago ricotta espinaca que hablaba
que blanqueó la los comemos están buenos
y buenísimos pero yo los pruebo y no no
eran los mismos le falta de esa mano la
mano de la abuela digamos del elsa bueno
aquí pasó lo mismo cada uno tiene su
forma digamos nuestra forma de lograr
eso
es conectar con el cliente y con
nosotros mismos es conexión humana
digamos es que todos nosotros los que
estamos habitando ese lugar chiquitito
en ese momento estemos muy conectados
como lo hacemos no lo sé sinceramente si
sé que hay algo que tiene que pasar
necesariamente para que eso ocurra y que
sin eso no puede ocurrir y eso es que
nosotros las 16 maravillosas personas
que trabajan ahí o sea
estén conectados en todo momento
nosotros seamos las nueve la mañana ocho
y media ocho depende de la julia empieza
a picar y cocinar y se empieza a generar
un ambiente una energía bastante extraña
al principio no
llegan los camareros y marcos
cuidadosamente ponen la servilleta en el
medio de la mesa en el costado izquierdo
y sigue subiendo subiendo subiendo
subiendo trabajamos nos reímos nos
volteamos un poquito también a la 8 de
la noche comemos todos juntos y ahí se
relaja un poquito de esta energía si la
comida rica buenísimo es mejor 8 y 4
bajamos todos a la reunión
marcos lee quienes vienen cuántas mesas
que comen cada uno si un aniversario si
hay alguna alergia si viene un amigo
todo eso yo les comento el menú que lo
acabamos de decidir es un ratito nos
decíamos buen servicio entre todos los
cocineros vuelven a la cocina
los camareros se van a la barra y
normalmente yo me quedé un poquito solo
en el salón
se prenden las velas 8 y 25 más o menos
ponen la música
baja la luz veo que las mesas están
dañadas por última vez
y a las ocho y media
se abre la puerta y entré al primer mesa
y ahí la magia empieza a suceder digamos
empiezan a salir los platos 400 platos
en total por noche que mucho
y nos empezamos a dar cuenta que esto
está pasando como nos damos cuenta por
cositas muy claras la señora en la mesa
3 está llorando porque el tema de phil
collins electoral es acordar su marido
el señor le mesa 6 vuelve el baño
riéndose con los chistes landriscina la
señora le mesa 8 nos pide ir a la cocina
y estaría un ratito con nosotros yo le
explico como la comanda
y así así muchas cosas y entre nosotros
también pasa nosotros durante el
servicio nos miramos y nos decimos bien
si vamos bien le sigamos así y seguimos
seguimos seguimos seguimos hacia la una
donde yo salgo la puerta normalmente y
despido el último cliente con un abrazo
un beso que quiero volver y qué sé yo se
van se cierra la puerta se prende la luz
y todos miramos así como bueno si ha
sido esa noche sí bueno buenísimo un
vinito hacia las tres de la mañana
charlando el servicio y todos muy
contentos y ha pasado eso esta noche
yo siempre muchos días cuando voy a
trabajar me pregunto casi todos los días
porque tanto porque tanto porque no
puede ser
a mi casa temprano porque no puede
llegar a una reunión de amigos antes a
la una de la mañana desubicado porque
los 35 años en la espalda triturada hoy
de 16 horas parados por día hace años
cuando pasan estas noches digo ahora por
esto la verdad
y entonces por eso les decía al
principio para nosotros el papá yo no es
solo un restaurant
el papayo el lugar en donde nosotros
somos felices haciendo lo que
lo que nos gusta hacer todos los días
y aquí somos felices haciendo feliz a
todas las personas que nos visitan
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah